avec lous lara al by adrien c'est une
équipe de choc qu'elena a réuni nom de
l'opération fête des pères c'est un
petit cactus impôts comme ça tout simple
avec plusieurs techniques d'origami
première partie fit le pot de bandes de
papier de couleur sont nécessaires l'une
de six centimètres par 5 et l'autre de 2
cm par 18 premières astuces d'elena se
servir de la table pour arrondir sa
bande de papier avant de le scotcher
pour former son thé la deuxième bande
vient ensuite faire le aux étapes
suivantes
le cactus avec une vente de 29 cm par 7
donc on va faire un accordéon et va chez
la femme
on cuit dans un sens puis dans attention
à être méticuleux et bien aligné les
piqûres
maintenant que vous avez ce papier en
accordez vous vous voyez on va réaliser
ces petites lignes en zigzag
on va se mettre à à peu près à un son
qui m et demi du haut et vous allez
plier comme puis vous allez reculé de 1
cm à peu près encore vous obtenez des
petits carrés sur lesquels il faut
tracer des diagonales à l'aide d'une
règle et d'un crayon
elles serviront de repères pour le
clivage est alors il va falloir plié en
zigzag sur chacun des traits que vous
avez fait de façon à ce que ça dessine
des dents de requins ne pas hésiter à
bien marquer le pli avec l'ongle
ensuite on replie l'accordéon donc on
alterne le long du zig zag que l'on a
créé avec les pluies ont fait leur
rentrée les prix leur intérieur
ne reste plus qu'à développer fixé son
cactus et l'empoter vous pouvez même
ajouter une fleur en décoration